problème avec lui c'est que philippe
bouvard est un petit peu plus petit que
moi je vais être obligé de retirer mes
chaussures
bonsoir bien suis très heureux d'être
parmi vous je remercie daniel gilbert de
m'avoir invité dans cette émission
et s'il vous le voulez bien et bien
jouer tout de suite demandé à l'une de
mes plus fidèles pensionnaires alice
sapritch de venir nous rejoindre par le
duplex que je vais tenter d'organiser
maintenant avec elle et jacques pierre
alors jacques pierre vous pouvez nous
envoyer alice sapritch s'il vous plaît
je pense que nous n'allons pas tarder à
l'avoir bonsoir alice ça va bien à l'isu
m'entendez ce que vous m'entendez soit
fini je vous entends très bien bonsoir
alice dites moi c'est charmant votre
petit intérieur là ce n'est pas mal
c'est un modeste appartement d'une femme
honnête oui puis votre robe est assez
sexy aussi c'est chouette ans avoue
trouver - c'est une robe que mon ami
paco rabanne fabrique pour 2,3 et les
bandits dont je suis pas venu pour
parler de votre garde-robe vous en
doutez bien alice non je suis venu quand
vous demander de nous parler de la
sexualité dont vous êtes un spécialiste
l'ont été sur philippe que vous alliez
me poser cette question saugrenue rond
non pas que la sexualité soit saugrenue
long non mais de la façon pour vous mais
menez je sais ce que vous allez me poser
comme question bon la sexualité j'avoue
que je commence à en avoir un peu marre
pourquoi parce que on ne parle que de ça
c'est à croire que les gens de banque
plus con et ça ça me gêne beaucoup
vraiment je fais un cours un court no
une rencontre avec de jeunes élèves mais
beaucoup les jeunes au lhc et aux études
kocian autre étude [ __ ]
vous venez de dire oui et bien je fais
une rencontre assez agréable dans
l'ensemble visage et un très charmant
ces jeunes élèves qui se destine à des
études l'austère souvent à l'arrière
austère et entre autres m'a causé aussi
des questions saugrenues dans le style
écoutez je suis bloqué bloqués sous
terre bloqués ridicule d'ailleurs je
suis bloqué est ce que vous croyez que
l'amour à plusieurs c'est plus naturel
je leur ai répondu écoutez ma petite
chérie je mets petit chéri jusqu'à
présent les fabricants d'un lit on fait
des lits pour une personne pour deux
personnes pour manou soyez gentils
utiliser les lits pour pour votre
partenaire c'est à dire pour deux
personnes et ne soyez pas 14 dans un
noyau là ce que je leur ai répondu tu
mens à l'iss après logique c'est normal
vous accepteriez de grimper au septième
ciel avec moi ah non je m'arrêterai au
premier est ce qu'il vous arrive d'être
agressés dans le métro quelques fois
alice ça marchera pas de mettre le métro
figure pour la bonne raison que je suis
très occupé je prends ou soit ma voiture
d'une production ou alors l'autobus
vous pouvez vous faire agresser dans
l'autobus non on ne m'adresse pas comme
ça non il ya d'autres personnes mieux
qualifiés que moi par ailleurs je vous
le fais pas dire alice vous avez des
projets actuellement chez ça ne vous
intéresse pas par exemple le fait que je
fasse mon métier avec un metteur en
scène je viens de tourner avec guy
lurçat domaine garçons avec sim comme
partenaire je viens de tourner avec
michel galabru le film de marc beurre
mais c'est je sais que ça ne nous
intéresse pas ce qui nous intéresse
c'est big three et bien soyons soyons
dans votre tonalité poison début du sri
ensemble si vous voulez bien dites-moi
alice sapritch pour terminer si vous
aviez un conseil à donner aux jeunes
qu'est ce que ce serait des plots se
seraient ceux ci baiser et n'en parlait
plus aux plaisirs madame merci et bon
soir